This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 I-Heart 播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84 年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在 AHA Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode of the show. Today, I am finally doing it. I am doing a much requested topic or episode, which is my guide to romanticizing our 20s, even when they suck. I think we've all seen videos or posts online about the importance of romanticizing your life, of romanticizing your 9 to 5, romanticizing your commute, your morning routine, whatever it is.
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论 20 多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听节目的另一集。今天，我终于要做了。我正在做一个备受期待的话题或剧集，那就是我关于浪漫化我们 20 多岁的指南，即使它们很糟糕。我想我们都在网上看过关于浪漫化你的生活、浪漫化你的朝九晚五、浪漫化你的通勤、你的晨间例行公事等等重要性的视频或帖子。
But why does this actually work? What does the psychology and the science say about these practices? And the biggest question of them all, is there any evidence? Is there any evidence that buying yourself the flowers, pretending you're the main character, using the good cutlery, the good candle, work? The answer I'm going to give it to you straight away is yes. There is so, so, much evidence. Honestly, so much evidence I could make this a two-parter that romanticizing your life does things to your mind, does things to your brain, does things to your body, then improve your quality of life. So today, we are going to talk about that, what romanticizing your 20s should actually look like. Of course, the neuroscience and the psychology behind
但为什么这真的有效呢？心理学和科学对这些做法有什么说法？最重要的问题是，有证据吗？有没有证据表明给自己买花、假装自己是主角、使用好的餐具、好的蜡烛是有用的？我要直接给你的答案是：是的。有非常、非常多的证据。老实说，证据多到我可以把它做成两部分，浪漫化你的生活会对你的思想、大脑和身体产生影响，从而提高你的生活质量。所以今天，我们将讨论这个问题，浪漫化你的 20 多岁实际上应该是什么样子。当然，还有背后的神经科学和心理学。
why and how this practice will quite literally change your reality and change the timeline you are on, but also my five personal favorite, you know, romanticizing techniques and tips that you probably are not doing or you may not have even heard of. So without further ado, let's get into the episode. When people talk about romanticizing, it often gets confused with sugar coding or even toxic positivity, like kind of like you're supposed to spin everything into a lesson and you are immediately meant to treat your pain. Like it is this gift, it's this It's this amazing thing. Everything happens for a reason.
为什么以及这种做法如何从字面上改变你的现实并改变你所处的轨道，还有我个人最喜欢的五个浪漫化技巧和窍门，你可能没有做过，甚至可能没听说过。所以事不宜迟，让我们进入这一集。当人们谈论浪漫化时，它经常与粉饰太平甚至有毒的正能量混淆，就像你本应把一切都变成一个教训，并且你应该立即把你的痛苦当作一份礼物，它是这个令人惊奇的事情。一切发生皆有原因。
Everything is how it should be. Everything is redirection. We have to be careful with this because it can turn into what we call in psychology emotional bypassing. Basically, not actually letting yourself feel the full spectrum of emotions and therefore emotionally depriving yourself of a big part of your human experience. Like we don't want to be doing that. Instead, romanticizing our 20s. as I see it personally, is choosing to experience your life as something you are actually experiencing, not just something that is happening to you or against you or with you as a victim.
一切都应该是这样。一切都是重定向。我们必须小心这一点，因为它可能会变成我们心理学中所说的情感绕过。基本上，就是不让自己真正感受到完整的情感光谱，从而在情感上剥夺了你人类体验的很大一部分。我们不想那样做。相反，浪漫化我们的 20 多岁，正如我个人所见，是选择去体验你的生活，作为你正在经历的事情，而不是仅仅作为发生在你身上、反对你或与你作为受害者一起发生的事情。
This is a mindset that honestly really has its roots in the 1800s with a movement called the Romantic Movement. To give you a history lesson, like the romantics were a group of people who really believed in the purpose and the importance of feeling experiences, getting the full complexity of it all, feeling deeply as a way to truth and enlightenment, even if it was more painful and messy than rationality. It is definitely a shift from this idea that your life is just a series of difficulties that you need to fix, to acknowledging that your life is an unfolding story, despite whether this chapter is hard or not, ultimately there is a purpose and ultimately
这是一种心态，老实说，它真正植根于 19 世纪的一场名为“浪漫主义运动”的运动。给你上一堂历史课，浪漫主义者是一群真正相信感受体验的目的和重要性的人，获得这一切的全部复杂性，深刻地感受作为通往真理和启蒙的途径，即使它比理性更痛苦和混乱。这绝对是从“你的生活只是一系列你需要解决的困难”这一观念的转变，转变为承认你的生活是一个正在展开的故事，无论这一章是否艰难，最终都有一个目的，最终
feeling is part of that purpose. Just notice for a second what I'm not saying. I'm not saying the hard chapter is fun. I'm not saying you have to be grateful for it. I'm saying it can be a chapter without being the whole story. And this is such an important emotional skill to develop during this decade because guess what? Bad things are going to happen to us in these years and the next. It's just without a doubt. It's the promise of life. Breakups, job rejection. loneliness, there is immediate pain there that has to be respected. And then there is the second layer of meaning that we get to control. And by doing so, that will actually shift your lived reality. Romanticizing your 20s is any form of exercise, practice, mindset shift that
感受是那个目的的一部分。请注意一下我没说的话。我不是说艰难的章节很有趣。我不是说你必须对此心存感激。我说它可以是一个章节，而不必是整个故事。这是在这个十年中培养的一项非常重要的情感技能，因为你猜怎么着？在这些年和未来，坏事会发生在我们身上。这是毫无疑问的。这是生活的承诺。分手、工作拒绝、孤独，那里有必须被尊重的直接痛苦。然后是我们可以控制的第二层意义。通过这样做，那将真正改变你的生活现实。浪漫化你的 20 多岁是任何形式的锻炼、练习、心态转变，
allows you to see your experiences as meaningful, even if they are actually terrible. Before we get into some of the specific practices for doing this that I have for you guys, how does this actually work? Like, I feel like I've been teasing this this whole episode, but like psychologically, clinically, scientifically, whatever. What is the perspective? What is the mechanism that makes this effective? The biggest reason romanticizing your life or your 20s works and makes your life and your 20s
让你能够将你的经历视为有意义的，即使它们实际上很糟糕。在我们进入我为你们准备的一些具体做法之前，这实际上是如何工作的？就像，我觉得我整集都在卖关子，但从心理学、临床、科学或其他方面来看。视角是什么？使之有效的机制是什么？浪漫化你的生活或 20 多岁之所以有效并让你的生活和 20 多岁
better is because of the power of cognitive reappraisal. So the theory behind cognitive reappraisal, which is one of the most famous. theories in psychology basically says you can change your emotional response by changing how you think about a situation, even if the situation stays the same, because your thoughts are half of the reality you're experiencing, by controlling those thoughts, you can give yourself a better outlook and a better outcome. Cognitive reappraisal, it's basically just a reality regulation strategy that is so well documented in the research, because essentially we know this. Two people could be experiencing the exact same thing. But the very fact that their past or their
变得更好的最大原因是认知重评的力量。所以认知重评背后的理论，这是心理学中最著名的理论之一，基本上说你可以通过改变你对情况的看法来改变你的情绪反应，即使情况保持不变，因为你的想法是你正在经历的现实的一半，通过控制这些想法，你可以给自己一个更好的前景和更好的结果。认知重评，它基本上只是一种现实调节策略，在研究中记录得非常好，因为本质上我们知道这一点。两个人可能正在经历完全相同的事情。但他们的过去或
intentions make them think about it differently would change the experience of that moment for them. And how you experience that single moment, the moment that you are in is really all that reality is ever based on. For example, a 2013 meta-analysis of neuroimaging studies, I don't even know how many they did, hundreds. it found that when people successfully reframed negative stimuli, so basically we're able to say, you know, this isn't all bad, this is what this could actually mean for me, I'm excited rather than anxious, I'm excited to see this unfold, the effect of this, of not just accepting negativity as it was, was visible in the brain. Often there was increased activity in the networks involved in cognitive control, meaning making, and also,
意图使他们以不同的方式思考它的事实会改变他们对那一刻的体验。而你如何体验那一刻，你所处的时刻，确实是所有现实所基于的一切。例如，2013 年一项关于神经影像研究的荟萃分析，我甚至不知道他们做了多少，数百项。它发现，当人们成功地重构负面刺激时，基本上我们能够说，你知道，这并不全是坏事，这实际上对我意味着什么，我很兴奋而不是焦虑，我很兴奋看到这一切展开，这种效果，不仅仅是接受消极情绪，在大脑中是可见的。通常，参与认知控制、意义构建的网络活动增加，而且，
reduced activity in brain regions associated with heightened emotional reactivity, such as the amygdala, which is very famous for that. So when we employ this reframing strategy, we're not, again, we're not changing the physical event. The physical event still sucks. What is actually happening to us is that we are just tapping into a psychological mechanism that our brain already has. Like our brain already has this ability to think differently about a situation. Sometimes it just forgets to use that because we are so emotionally overwhelmed by all of this stuff landing at our doorstep at once that we just don't use it and we just find it easier just to accept things as they are. Models in cognitive neuroscience will often describe the brain as a prediction machine. It uses past experiences to generate expectations about what is going to happen and what will happen.
与高度情绪反应相关的大脑区域活动减少，例如杏仁核，它在这方面非常出名。所以当我们采用这种重构策略时，我们不是，再说一次，我们不是在改变物理事件。物理事件仍然很糟糕。实际上发生在我们身上的是，我们只是在利用我们大脑已经具备的一种心理机制。就像我们的大脑已经具备了以不同方式思考情况的能力。有时它只是忘记使用它，因为我们被所有这些同时降临到我们家门口的东西在情感上压垮了，以至于我们只是不使用它，我们只是觉得接受现状更容易。认知神经科学中的模型通常将大脑描述为预测机器。它利用过去的经验来生成关于将要发生什么和将会发生什么的期望。
and what will happen next, basically. And then it updates those predictions based on incoming sensory data, like incoming environmental stimuli. Part of that data, it's using all your deliberate thoughts and how you choose to interpret something. That is part of the data set. So this means that what you expect, therefore shapes what you notice. When an event, life happens,
以及接下来会发生什么，基本上。然后它根据传入的感官数据，比如传入的环境刺激，更新这些预测。部分数据，它正在使用你所有的深思熟虑的想法以及你选择如何解释某事。那是数据集的一部分。所以这意味着你的期望，从而塑造了你注意到的东西。当一个事件，生活发生时，
it means that that perception will be different. I feel like I'm going on a lot about this. Why does this matter for your 20s? Well, when you were experiencing a time full of ambiguous situations, the brain leans hardest on what it can predict and what it can expect to overcome that uncertainty. So if your internal model believes you're behind, if your internal model keeps telling you like, nothing works out for me, I'm always going to fail, it's easy to take that as a fact if you never question it, and it's easy to apply that same narrative to entirely neutral situations. You know, the quiet weekend becomes evidence that you lack friends. The endless job hunt becomes evidence that you're just not smart
这意味着那种感知将是不同的。我觉得我在这方面说了很多。这对你的 20 多岁有什么影响？好吧，当你经历一个充满模糊情况的时期时，大脑最依赖它能预测什么以及它能期望什么来克服这种不确定性。所以如果你的内部模型认为你落后了，如果你的内部模型一直告诉你，比如，没有什么对我来说是顺利的，我总是会失败，如果你从不质疑它，很容易把它当作事实，并且很容易将同样的叙述应用于完全中性的情况。你知道，安静的周末变成了你缺乏朋友的证据。无休止的求职变成了你不够聪明的证据
enough. That isn't always true. People are busy. The job market is tough right now. Sometimes you have to take yourself out of that situation and view it differently and view it objectively, whether that is through a romantic lens or something else entirely. So romanticizing though it's basically it's choosing that deliberate pathway. It's saying I'm going to reprogram how I am seeing this and give my brain a broader, kinder, more realistic hypothesis for why things are happening to me. Like, this is a hard part of the story and I'm going to get over it. This is my origin story. This is what's going to make me more resilient in the future. this is just part of life's ups and downs.
那并不总是真的。人们很忙。就业市场现在很艰难。有时你必须让自己脱离那种情况，以不同的方式看待它，客观地看待它，无论是通过浪漫的镜头还是完全不同的东西。所以浪漫化，虽然它基本上是选择那条深思熟虑的道路。它是在说，我将重新编程我看到这种情况的方式，并为我大脑提供一个更广泛、更友善、更现实的假设，说明为什么事情会发生在我身上。比如，这是故事中艰难的一部分，我会克服它。这是我的起源故事。这就是未来让我更具韧性的原因。这只是生活起伏的一部分。
There are other reasons that these things are happening to me that may not just immediately be the reason that I understand, which is that nothing good happens to me, life sucks, this is terrible, I'm not going to be able to get through it. That shift, again, that can change what your brain sees its evidence. It also really comes down to the power of attention, right? I feel like we talk about attention so much on this podcast because it is your most lucrative tool, your most lucrative resource when it comes to your mental
还有其他原因导致这些事情发生在我身上，可能不仅仅是我立即理解的原因，那就是没有什么好事发生在我身上，生活很糟糕，这太可怕了，我无法度过难关。那种转变，再说一次，可以改变你的大脑视为证据的东西。这也确实归结为注意力的力量，对吧？我觉得我们在这个播客上谈论注意力太多了，因为它是你最赚钱的工具，你最赚钱的资源，当涉及到你的心理
well-being. It is our way, attention is our way of basically allocating our mental resources. Your brain is processing so much information more than you could ever consciously experience. You listen to our Conscious versus Unconscious Mind episode, you will know this very well. there are sounds you don't notice, facial expressions you don't register, body sensations you tune out, thoughts that flicker by too fast to catch. So the brain has to be selective and it has to develop the systems to be selective. Attention is that selection system. It decides what gets priority processing, what gets amplified and what gets kind of pushed into the background or like basically just ignored. We can understand this through what we call. We can understand this through what we
健康时。它是我们的方式，注意力是我们基本上分配心理资源的方式。你的大脑正在处理的信息比你所能有意识体验到的要多得多。你听过我们的《意识与潜意识》那一集，你就会非常清楚这一点。有些声音你没有注意到，面部表情你没有记录，身体感觉你忽略了，想法闪过太快而无法捕捉。所以大脑必须有选择性，它必须开发系统来变得有选择性。注意力就是那个选择系统。它决定什么获得优先处理，什么被放大，什么被推到背景中，或者基本上只是被忽略。我们可以通过我们所说的来理解这一点。我们可以通过我们所说的来理解这一点，
call, well, I guess it's like the idea, the idea of biased competition. It's this model that was proposed by two American psychologists or I guess neuroscientists way back in the day, I think, in like the 1990s, which is not way back in the day, but a couple decades ago. This model basically argues that stimuli compete for neural representation, basically brain space. And what attention does is turn our biases towards whatever is currently relevant to our current mindset and our way of seeing the world. Basically, our attention is guided by our goals, guided by our self-knowledge, guided by our expectations that we get to set deliberately. So if you start to notice good, if you start to notice that everything goes right for me, if you start to believe that everything
嗯，我猜这就像那个想法，那个偏向竞争的想法。这是两位美国心理学家，或者我猜是神经科学家在很久以前提出的模型，我想，在 1990 年代，这并不是很久以前，而是几十年前。这个模型基本上认为刺激竞争神经表征，基本上是大脑空间。而注意力所做的是将我们的偏见转向任何与我们当前心态和我们看待世界的方式相关的东西。基本上，我们的注意力是由我们的目标引导的，由我们的自我知识引导的，由我们能够深思熟虑设定的期望引导的。所以如果你开始注意到好的，如果你开始注意到一切对我来说都很顺利，如果你开始相信一切
goes right for you or whatever it is, like your brain focuses on that more. basically like a big part of romanticizing your 20s is saying let's let me recognize the ordinary let me recognize the good let me recognize what I'm grateful for things that signify a life of abundance things that signify a plan that signify things are getting better if I focus on that this fine tunes my attentional system to basically search for that more meaning it becomes a larger more meaningful part of my reality meaning that my behavior and my reality continues to match my expectations because of how I choose to react in response. When people say, like, what you focus on expands, this is the more scientific way of understanding that. What you
对你来说都很顺利，或者无论它是什么，就像你的大脑更多地关注这一点。基本上，浪漫化你的 20 多岁的一大部分是在说，让我认识到平凡，让我认识到美好，让我认识到我感激什么，那些象征着富足生活的事物，那些象征着计划的事物，那些象征着事情正在好转的事物，如果我专注于此，这会微调我的注意力系统，基本上去寻找更多意义，它成为我现实中更大、更有意义的一部分，这意味着我的行为和我的现实继续符合我的期望，因为我选择如何反应。当人们说，比如，你关注什么就会扩展什么，这是理解这一点的更科学的方式。你
consistently attend to becomes more salient, more encoded, more retrievable, and more likely to form the basis of your sense of self, and more likely to form the basis of your sense of your 20s, basically. There's one more psychological reason that romanticizing our 20s works, beyond attention, beyond this resource allocation. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
持续关注的东西变得更显著、更编码、更可检索，并且更有可能构成你自我意识的基础，并且更有可能构成你 20 多岁意识的基础，基本上。浪漫化我们的 20 多岁有效的心理原因还有一个，超越注意力，超越这种资源分配。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex, pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等交谈，以超越统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是炎症性的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jay.
请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crows. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈 80 年代的快克。需要明确的是，84 年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上也有艾滋病。
Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience
谢谢你完成那句话。我不认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我十多年来的个人经验
in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
在心理健康领域，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了那个东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同的信任水平。我希望你真的做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
在我们关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目的的真实对话中，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中。打开你免费的 IHeart Radio 应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。
Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
格雷，那个女同性恋，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们，先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。第一条规则，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条规则，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
Let me quickly return to that one final thing. I said, I kind of mentioned before, which is the role of the narrative, the role of having a story for your 20s and believing that there is this underlying current of things working out or things taking you in the right direction. I think this is my most talked about matter on the podcast. I'm sorry if you are a frequent listener because we are returning to it yet again. It is just so essential to literally every single thing you choose to do in this 10-year period of your life. Like narrative psychology, if I could, if I could have every 20-something
让我快速回到最后一点。我之前提到过，那就是叙事的作用，为你的 20 多岁拥有一个故事的作用，并相信有一种潜在的趋势，即事情会好转，或者事情会把你带向正确的方向。我认为这是我在播客上谈论最多的话题。如果你是一个经常收听的听众，我很抱歉，因为我们又回到了它。它对于你在人生这十年里选择做的每一件事都至关重要。就像叙事心理学，如果我可以，如果我可以让每一个 20 多岁的人
know one-time it would be the idea of narrative psychology. It's the idea that there is an objective story of what's happening in your life. That objective story may be, you know, I don't have as many friends as I want. I don't like my job. My job is not fulfilling. I don't have the money I need to do the things I want. And then there is the narrative that you tell yourself about that story, which is that. you know, it's what makes it meaningful. What makes those objective experiences meaningful and sentimental. Like, again, that story of, yeah, everything, this is actually important. This suffering is important. I am getting closer to what I want. I am learning important skills.
知道一件事，那就是叙事心理学的概念。这是一个想法，即你的生活中发生的事情有一个客观的故事。那个客观的故事可能是，你知道，我没有我想要的那么多朋友。我不喜欢我的工作。我的工作没有成就感。我没有我需要的钱去做我想做的事情。然后是你对自己讲述的关于那个故事的叙事，那就是。你知道，这正是让它有意义的原因。是什么让那些客观的经历变得有意义和感伤。就像，再说一次，那个故事，是的，一切，这实际上很重要。这种痛苦很重要。我正在接近我想要的。我正在学习重要的技能。
That's why I'm going through this. This is the story about the story. In the early 2000s, researchers based in Germany wrote this fantastic, this huge fantastic paper talking about this and talking about the idea of life story coherence. And it basically means that you are able to organize events in a way that makes sense over time, especially through casual coherence, basically how your experiences are shaping you, and thematic coherence, like recurring themes that you carry with you. That coherence develops over your 20s. And actually a 2014 study published in the Journal of Personality looked at
这就是我经历这一切的原因。这是关于故事的故事。在 21 世纪初，位于德国的研究人员写了这篇精彩的、巨大的精彩论文，讨论了这个话题，并讨论了生活故事连贯性的概念。它基本上意味着你能够以一种随着时间推移有意义的方式组织事件，特别是通过因果连贯性，基本上你的经历是如何塑造你的，以及主题连贯性，比如你随身携带的反复出现的主题。这种连贯性在你的 20 多岁时发展。事实上，2014 年发表在《人格杂志》上的一项研究观察了
looked at the autobiographical narratives of personally significant events from all these people, like 103 students, I think. And what they did was they looked at the story people were telling themselves about their lives and they coded these stories based on whether they were coherent, based on whether they contained content about their identity, based on whether they were inherently optimistic. And what the researchers found was that participants who constructed a more coherent narrative of events, like this thing had to happen to lead into this thing and this thing had to happen to lead into this thing and failure as redirection and this all makes sense in the flow of my life, they had improved psychological well-being.
观察了所有这些人对个人重大事件的自传叙事，比如 103 名学生，我想。他们所做的是观察人们对自己生活讲述的故事，并根据这些故事是否连贯、是否包含关于他们身份的内容、是否本质上是乐观的来对这些故事进行编码。研究人员发现，构建了更连贯事件叙事的参与者，比如这件事必须发生才能导致这件事，这件事必须发生才能导致这件事，失败是重定向，这一切在我的生活流程中都有意义，他们改善了心理健康。
If you were able to take moments of failure as lessons, if you are able to think that your story was building to something greater, if you are able to see that everything in life is connected, even the hard parts, like even the hard parts are still fascinating and still worthwhile in some way because they capture a part of the human condition because they are necessary stepping stones, that will make you happier. That made these people happier. This is why it is so important to reflect or create a story for your life, to explain your experiences, even the ones that suck. That is so protective. So with that in mind, let's jump into some of my actual tips for romanticizing your life, actual tips for connecting to a story about your life.
如果你能够把失败的时刻当作教训，如果你能够认为你的故事正在建立某种更伟大的东西，如果你能够看到生活中的一切都是相互联系的，即使是艰难的部分，比如即使是艰难的部分仍然是迷人的，并且在某种程度上仍然是值得的，因为它们捕捉到了人类状况的一部分，因为它们是必要的垫脚石，那会让你更快乐。这让这些人更快乐。这就是为什么反思或为你的生活创造一个故事，来解释你的经历，即使是那些糟糕的经历，是如此重要。这非常有保护作用。所以考虑到这一点，让我们进入我的一些浪漫化生活的实际技巧，连接到关于你生活的故事的实际技巧。
Number one, every good story, every good movie needs a good soundtrack. So if you want to romanticize your 20s, make playlists for every life chapter and moment. Firstly, music is one of the most widely and most historically used emotional regulation tools across culture, across cultures, I should say, across age groups, whether that's for comfort, destruction, I don't know, processing anger. It provides catharsis. And I think music also provides a bit of beauty to heart emotions because it allows you to feel it all so deeply, which again is part of the blessing of being alive, whether we want to acknowledge that or not. Secondly, a playlist has the potential to do something really quite amazing when you think about it. It creates a
第一，每一个好故事，每一部好电影都需要一个好的配乐。所以如果你想浪漫化你的 20 多岁，为每一个生活章节和时刻制作播放列表。首先，音乐是跨文化、跨年龄组最广泛、历史上使用最多的情绪调节工具之一，无论是为了安慰、破坏，我不知道，处理愤怒。它提供了宣泄。而且我认为音乐也为痛苦的情绪提供了一点美感，因为它让你如此深刻地感受到这一切，这再次是活着的一种祝福，无论我们是否想承认这一点。其次，当你想到它时，播放列表有潜力做一些非常令人惊奇的事情。它创造了一个
container for where you are able to fully feel your emotions and then return to that later. It contains a feeling based on our associations with those songs. Because of our psychological attachment to music, the memories created with that music last and are able to be revisited and thought about. When you're heartbroken, I think, when you're moving, when you're homesick, whatever, your feelings can feel very endless, very shapeless. So a playlist gives you emotional boundaries. It helps you move through your emotions.
容器，你可以在其中充分感受你的情绪，然后稍后再回到那里。它包含了一种基于我们与这些歌曲关联的感觉。由于我们对音乐的心理依恋，用那种音乐创造的记忆会持续存在，并且能够被重温和思考。当你心碎时，我想，当你搬家时，当你思乡时，无论什么，你的感觉可能会感到非常无尽，非常没有形状。所以播放列表给了你情感边界。它帮助你度过你的情绪。
And it means that in 10 years time, 15 years time, maybe even less, two years time, you'll be able to listen back to that music. Feel the feeling you felt then and appreciate it differently. Appreciate it as kind of like as part of the story so that you gain that coherence. You know, make sure that you continue, that you try to use music to categorize and appreciate your life. Like if there's a song that makes you feel really ethereal and beautiful, a song that makes you feel really nostalgic,
这意味着在 10 年后，15 年后，甚至更短，两年后，你将能够回听那段音乐。感受你当时感受到的感觉，并以不同的方式欣赏它。欣赏它作为故事的一部分，这样你就获得了那种连贯性。你知道，确保你继续，你尝试使用音乐来分类和欣赏你的生活。比如，如果有一首歌让你感觉非常空灵和美丽，一首歌让你感觉非常怀旧，
a song that makes you feel heartbroken, use those songs to bookmark moments in your experience. Think of it, think of, like, how impactful, like a film soundtrack is. It can literally change how you interpret a scene, and it makes you associate certain songs with certain moments. Do that with your life. I want you to make yourself a movie soundtrack to, like, all the different moments,
一首歌让你感觉心碎，使用这些歌曲来标记你经历中的时刻。想想，想想，比如，电影配乐有多大的影响力。它可以从字面上改变你解释场景的方式，并且它让你将某些歌曲与某些时刻联系起来。用你的生活做这件事。我希望你为自己制作一部电影配乐，比如，所有不同的时刻，
in, you know, the near past future as a way to romanticize them and feel them even more deeply and then to be able to return to them when you're feeling differently to understand that those emotions pass. Like, playlist for the first week of 2026 winter, for the dinner party with your friends, for your first breakup, for processing rejection, have those playlists, make these playlist as, I don't know, little companions to the moments in your life so that you can feel it deeply. Tip number two, make your alone time romantic and make it really, just make it really, really, really special. Make it incredibly special to you to spend time with yourself. I honestly blame film and TV and social media for this insidious idea that being alone means
在，你知道，不久的将来，作为一种浪漫化它们并更深刻地感受它们的方式，然后当你感觉不同时能够回到它们，以理解那些情绪会过去。比如，2026 年冬天的第一周的播放列表，和你朋友的晚宴，你的第一次分手，处理拒绝，拥有那些播放列表，制作这些播放列表作为，我不知道，你生活中时刻的小伴侣，这样你就可以深刻地感受到它。技巧二，让你的独处时间浪漫化，让它真的，只是让它真的、真的、真的特别。让你花时间陪伴自己变得非常特别。我老实说，责怪电影、电视和社交媒体这种阴险的想法，即独处意味着
you're automatically lonely, especially when we constantly see these people, these images of others with like their big friendship groups and like their perfect relationships and like their interesting Saturday night plans, like they're at the bar, then they're at the restaurant, then they're like at a show and everybody's having a great time. We want that. But actually a lot of us in our 20s are alone more than we ever expected to be and more than other people realize we are. Not always physically alone. Sometimes it's more like a feeling. Like, you have people around you, but no one really knows what's going on inside you. I think this causes a huge amount of disappointment in us, you know, as if being single or staying
你自动感到孤独，特别是当我们不断看到这些人，这些其他人与他们的大型朋友圈、完美的恋爱关系和有趣的周六晚上计划的图像时，比如他们在酒吧，然后他们在餐厅，然后他们在看演出，每个人都玩得很开心。我们想要那个。但实际上，我们 20 多岁的人独处的时间比我们预期的要多，也比其他人意识到的要多。并不总是身体上的独处。有时它更像是一种感觉。比如，你周围有人，但没有人真正知道你内心发生了什么。我认为这导致了我们巨大的失望，你知道，好像单身或周六晚上呆在家里或没有一个大的朋友圈意味着你做错了。而且我们并不总是意识到，比如，独处是重要的，并且在心理上具有保护作用。当然，比如，社区支持网络增加了你的寿命。它们非常重要。我不是说花你所有的时间独处，但我认为如果你想感到快乐，让你的独处时间浪漫和特别非常重要。有一篇来自《人格与社会心理学公报》的非常有趣的论文，探讨了独处作为自我调节的一个非常重要的方面，
in on a Saturday night or not having a big friend group means you're doing this wrong. And we don't always realize, like, solitude is important and psychologically protective. Of course, like, community support networks add years to your life. They're so important. I'm not saying like spend all your time alone, but I think making your alone time romantic and special is so important if you want to feel happy. There's a really interesting paper from the personality and social psychology bulletin that explores solitude as a really important aspect of self-regulation,
基本上能够把你带回你自己。这是我能想到的最好的说法。研究发现，当我们主动选择练习时，独处实际上有助于减少负面情绪的强度。这里的关键是主动选择，而不是感觉我们被动地被扔进了一个我们不想进入的独处状态。来自写作大学研究人员的进一步研究将这种选择和刻意培养你独处的过程称为“创造独处”。他们谈到了有意为之并让你的独处时间变得有意义的重要性
basically being able to bring yourself back into yourself. That's the best way I can put it. The research has found that solitude actually helps reduce, the intensity of negative emotions when it is something that we deliberately choose to practice. The key here is actively choosing rather than feeling like we are passively being thrown into an alone state we don't want to be in. A further study from researchers at the University of Writing called this process of choosing and deliberately cultivating your solitude as crafting solitude. And they talk about the importance of being intentional and making your alone time meaningful
和充实。比如有意识地想到一场音乐会或戏剧或你想去看的比赛，然后决定，我要自己去做，而不是等待失望并觉得我在独处方面没有选择。带自己去一个可爱的约会。周日没有计划。所以选择让它对你自己来说非常特别，通过烹饪你最喜欢的饭菜，或者烹饪像一顿美丽、美丽的早餐，或者独自去长途徒步旅行，让你的房间变得非常、非常舒适，为晚上准备好你的护肤品。比如，那些小的转变，比如，我在这里有选择，我有代理权，我喜欢这样做，改变了围绕独处的这种情感负荷，使它成为你感到兴奋的事情。
and full. Like consciously thinking of a concert or a play or a game you really want to go to and then deciding, I'm going to do that by myself instead of waiting to be disappointed and feel like I don't have a choice in being alone. Taking yourself out for a cute date. Having no plans on a Sunday. So choosing to make it really special for yourself by cooking your favorite meal, or cooking like a beautiful, beautiful breakfast or going for a long hike by yourself, getting your room really, really cozy, getting your skincare lined up for the night. Like, those small shifts of like, I have a choice here, I have agency, I love doing this, changes the emotional charge around solitude to make it something you're excited about
并且感到充实。就像有意识地去想一场你非常想去的音乐会、戏剧或比赛，然后决定，我要自己去，而不是等着失望，感觉自己别无选择只能孤独一人。带自己去进行一场可爱的约会。周日没有计划。所以选择通过做你最喜欢的饭菜，或者做一顿非常非常精美的早餐，或者独自去进行一次长途徒步旅行，把你的房间布置得非常非常舒适，为晚上准备好护肤品，来让这一天变得非常特别。就像这些小小的转变，比如，我在这里有选择权，我有自主权，我喜欢这样做，改变了围绕孤独的情绪负荷，使它成为你感到兴奋的事情。
and you can really gain psychological insight from. I also think for those of us who want kids, like want to get married, want families, there will be a time in your life when you will look back at these solitary moments with envy and with like a deep desire to have one more night in your own bed, one more night alone, one more day where you didn't have to follow an itinerary or tell people what to do, one more day where you had like no plan. Here is that chance. You know, do it for your future self.
并且你可以从中获得真正的心理洞察。我也认为，对于我们这些想要孩子、想要结婚、想要家庭的人来说，你生命中总会有那么一个时刻，你会带着羡慕和深深的渴望回望这些独处的时光，渴望能再有一个夜晚独自躺在自己的床上，再有一个夜晚独自一人，再有一天不需要遵循行程安排，不需要告诉别人该做什么，再有一天没有任何计划。现在就是这个机会。你知道，为了未来的自己去做吧。
Do it for the future you. Part of that is, again, really appreciating every chapter you're in for what you may miss one day, really appreciating, you know, yeah, I'm lonely and that sucks, but one day I'm going to miss being lonely. Oh, yeah, I'm heartbroken and whatever. But, like, one day I'm going to be in love and miss this feeling. In the same vein, I think one of the easiest ways to romanticize your 20s is just to create any kind of ritual. Yeah, rituals around being alone, but rituals for when you get your first paycheck and a new job. rituals for getting ghosted, rituals for every job rejection, rituals for every single first date.
为了未来的自己去做吧。这其中的一部分，同样是真正去欣赏你所处的每一个人生阶段，因为你终有一天会怀念它。真正去欣赏，你知道，是的，我很孤独，这感觉很糟糕，但总有一天我会怀念这种孤独。哦，是的，我心碎了，诸如此类。但是，总有一天我会坠入爱河，并怀念这种感觉。同样地，我认为浪漫化二十岁最简单的方法之一，就是创造任何一种仪式感。是的，关于独处的仪式，关于你拿到第一份工资和新工作时的仪式，关于被“冷暴力”分手后的仪式，关于每一次求职被拒的仪式，关于每一次第一次约会的仪式。
These are essential. Rituals sound very spiritual, like prayer, like something like that. But there's a lot of research actually showing that having sacred sentimental practices for key life events or even really minor events, like helps people cope with uncertainty by creating something you can control that you find cleansing, that you find calming or romantic, and you can keep returning to it, because again, it's something that you control. There's one specific study from 2014, from researchers at Harvard, that actually found how rituals can be particularly healing for people going through really
这些至关重要。仪式听起来很神圣，像祈祷之类的。但实际上有很多研究表明，为关键的人生事件甚至是非常微小的事件建立神圣的情感实践，有助于人们通过创造一些你可以控制的、让你感到净化、平静或浪漫的事物来应对不确定性，你可以不断地回归到这些仪式中，因为归根结底，这是你可以掌控的事情。哈佛大学的研究人员在2014年进行了一项具体的研究，发现仪式对于那些正在经历非常
hard things, like specifically people who are grieving. That's why visiting gravesites is so important. by lighting candles, continuing to celebrate the birthdays of those who have passed, can be so powerful because it continues to keep a part of them alive and keep certainty and a sense of control over things that feel uncontrollable. It allows us to feel, again, like, yeah, control, but also like there is some magic. There's some peace, there's stability to moments that are really hard. everything around you could fall apart and you could still light that incense at the end of the night.
艰难事情的人，特别是那些正在经历丧亲之痛的人，具有特别的治愈作用。这就是为什么扫墓如此重要。点燃蜡烛，继续庆祝逝者的生日，可以产生如此强大的力量，因为它让逝者的一部分生命得以延续，并在那些感觉无法控制的事情中保持确定性和掌控感。它让我们再次感觉到，是的，有掌控感，但也感觉到某种魔力。在非常艰难的时刻，会有一些平静和稳定。即使你周围的一切都可能分崩离析，你依然可以在深夜点燃那支香。
You could still make sure that you walked outside for 20 minutes every day. I also think rituals in our 20s make the ordinary feel important and significant, which we sometimes lose by being in such a rush to get places and like tick things off a list and be successful and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And they help us mark points in time. They help us like maybe even mentally close certain chapters or open certain chapters. we're like, cool, I'm here. I'm in this moment. I'm not in that moment anymore. Let me give you some examples so that you can kind of see what I'm saying here. The biggest one I think of is
你依然可以确保每天出去走上20分钟。我也认为，二十岁时的仪式感让平凡变得重要而有意义，而我们有时因为急于到达某个地方、急于完成清单上的事项、急于获得成功等等，而失去了这种感觉。它们帮助我们标记时间节点。它们甚至可以帮助我们在心理上结束某些篇章或开启某些篇章。我们就像是，酷，我在这里。我正处于这个时刻。我不再处于那个时刻了。让我给你举几个例子，这样你就能明白我的意思了。我想到的最重要的一个是
I have a ritual. When I start a new job, I always use a small part of my paycheck to buy myself something really nice that I know will last. Like a gift to myself, like a nice pair of earrings, a handbag, I think I did that one once. Something that I know I'm going to have for years that signifies this new chapter. This literally started like when I was, how old was I when I got my first job? 14, nine months, like 15. And I got my first paycheck. It was $200, which is actually quite a lot of money, but I think I'd worked like a lot of shifts. And I bought myself a pair of ripped denim jeans, no shorts from one teaspoon. I don't know if you guys remember that brand. Those shorts did not last. They were so ripped. It was almost inappropriate. But the practice is still there. I've done that for every
我有一个仪式。当我开始一份新工作时，我总是会用工资的一小部分给自己买一件真正好的、我知道能用很久的东西。就像送给自己的一份礼物，比如一副漂亮的耳环，一个手提包，我想我曾经做过一次。我知道我会拥有它很多年，它象征着这个新篇章。这实际上是从我，我得到第一份工作时多大来着？14岁，九个月，大概15岁。我拿到了第一份工资。那是200美元，其实是一笔不小的钱，但我记得我做了很多轮班。我给自己买了一条破洞牛仔短裤，来自One Teaspoon。我不知道你们是否还记得那个品牌。那条短裤没穿多久。它破得太厉害了。几乎都不太得体了。但这个习惯一直保留了下来。我为每一次
job, every contract since. I actually didn't do anything for my Netflix deal, which I still feel like I need to do. So I'm breaking my own ritual. It's just been very busy. But yeah, I have one item from every past job I've started. Another ritual is having a specific first date outfit or a first date perfume. And on the other end of the spectrum, obviously, like, different life experience, but having a break up ritual. After you break up, go get a bad haircut, rearrange your bedroom, take everything they gave you, box it all up, burn it, bury it, store it, that sort of thing as a cleansing thing to be like, cool, that chapter is done. I'm ready to psychologically move forward. I physically closed the door. Another ritual, something I actually started doing last year was that I, well, this
工作，每一次合同都这样做过。其实我为我的Netflix合约什么都没买，我觉得我还是需要买点什么。所以我打破了自己的仪式。只是最近太忙了。但是的，我为我开始的每一份过去的工作都留有一件物品。另一个仪式是拥有一套特定的第一次约会服装或第一约会香水。而在光谱的另一端，显然，是不同的人生经历，但拥有一个分手仪式。分手后，去剪个糟糕的发型，重新布置卧室，把你前任给你的所有东西都装进盒子里，烧掉、埋掉、存起来，诸如此类，作为一种净化，就像是，酷，那个篇章结束了。我准备好在心理上向前看了。我在物理上关上了那扇门。另一个仪式，我去年开始做的一件事是，我，嗯，今年
year I started to walk the number of kilometers as the same, like the age I was turning, I took that age and did that number of kilometers as a walk. That is the most complicated way of describing this, but basically turn 26, walk 26 kilometers. Turn 29, walk 29 kilometers. Start at 9 a.m. Daugle along, invite some friends. And it kind of signifies a new year. Like, I'm doing this hard thing, and I'm seeing a new thing, and I'm doing something that marks that this is what I did on this birthday instead of doing nothing. I think rituals around birthdays and aging are amazing to symbolize like the privilege of getting older and just again make your birthday feel special so that time feels marked by these moments same for the start of a new year same for the start of a new season
我开始按照我即将迎来的岁数去走相应的公里数，我取那个岁数，然后走那个公里数的路。这是描述这件事最复杂的方式，但基本上就是26岁时，走26公里。29岁时，走29公里。早上9点出发。慢慢走，邀请一些朋友。这象征着新的一年。就像，我正在做这件困难的事，我正在看到新的事物，我正在做一些事情来标记我在这个生日做了什么，而不是什么都不做。我认为围绕生日和变老的仪式感非常棒，它象征着变老的特权，再次让你的生日感觉特别，让时间被这些时刻所标记，新的一年开始时也是如此，新季节开始时也是如此。
new cities new life like that sort of thing it marks things in time it says that that everything in life every experience is still important and during transitional times it also stops us from keeping things like open-ended that can kind of i don't know kind of cast a shadow over us Okay, we're going to take one final short break with this episode before I dive into my final two tips for romanticizing our 20s and when we maybe shouldn't romanticize hard things. And we should just let ourselves feel a little bit crap. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
新的城市，新的生活，诸如此类，它标记了时间，它说明生活中的一切，每一次经历依然很重要，在过渡时期，它也阻止我们让事情保持一种悬而未决的状态，这可能会，我不知道，可能会给我们投下阴影。好了，在进入我浪漫化二十岁的最后两个建议，以及我们什么时候或许不应该浪漫化困难的事情，而是应该让自己感觉糟糕一点之前，我们要进行本集的最后一次简短休息。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building with. resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家交谈，更多地去审视那些主导健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的吗？我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
收听《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“TWO%”。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了利尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和利尔·金有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何幸存下来的。包括最近一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克毒品。说清楚，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我整天都愿意谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你帮我把那句话说完。我不认为还有比这更重要的黑人年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够多了。因为人们在盯着记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要。你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争来证明真相。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never. Mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
第一条规则，永远。不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条规则，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own. own hands. I said, oh, hell no, I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I did this episode on Wimsy, like a month or two ago now, and it kind of blew up. You guys loved it. It like strangely went viral on Instagram, which side note, the comments are
我感觉就像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们采取了行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不，我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。我大概一两个月前做了关于“奇思妙想”的那一集，它有点火了。你们很喜欢它。它在Instagram上奇怪地疯传，顺便说一句，评论是
honestly quite funny. I had no idea whimsie could be so controversial. Like people were up in arms. Like people were angry in those comments. But that's besides the point. Something I spoke about in that episode, if you haven't listened to it, it's amazing. Please go listen to it. Which not to my own horn, but it's a great episode. Something I spoke about is the importance of collecting and representing your memories through trinkets, small souvenirs, through junk. During your 20s, We are constantly shedding the skin of the person we used to be and shedding the life of the people we used to be. And sometimes we look back on a year and we wonder like, where the heck did all the time go? I have nothing to remember this time by.
老实说相当有趣。我没想到“奇思妙想”会如此有争议。人们简直是群情激愤。评论里的人很生气。但那不是重点。我在那一集中谈到的一件事，如果你还没听过，它很棒。请去听听。虽然不是自吹自擂，但这是一集很棒的节目。我谈到的是通过小饰品、小纪念品、通过垃圾来收集和代表你的记忆的重要性。在二十岁时，我们不断地蜕去曾经的自己的皮，蜕去曾经的生活。有时我们回望一年，我们会想，时间到底去哪儿了？我没有什么可以记住这段时间的。
And we struggle to actually think and appreciate what we've done. By collecting trinkets, by collecting postcards, notes, whatever it is, these actors cues for our memories. It's one way to kind of prevent that evaporation of time that a lot of us experience. The 2021 study in Australia found that possessions like souvenirs, like photographs, really any object that is meaningfully attached to a time or moment, can actually preserve that experience for us and make the moment feel more vibrant, feel more important in hindsight, and of course, feel more romantic with the capital R, feel more deep. Think about when you were a child. I know I used to collect shells from the beach.
我们很难真正去思考和欣赏我们所做过的事情。通过收集小饰品、明信片、笔记，无论是什么，这些都是我们记忆的线索。这是防止我们许多人经历的那种时间蒸发的一种方法。2021年在澳大利亚的一项研究发现，像纪念品、照片这样的财产，真的任何与某个时间和时刻有意义地联系在一起的物体，实际上都可以为我们保存那种体验，并使那个时刻在事后感觉更生动、更重要，当然，感觉更浪漫（大写的R），感觉更深刻。想想你小时候。我知道我过去常从海滩收集贝壳。
And when I was a kid, which apparently you're not meant to do anymore, so I'm very sorry, but I was a kid back then. Nobody knew anything. I used to collect beanie babies. I used to, I don't know, collect little figurines, and I still have so many of them. And it physically is very grounding, and it physically feels like I'm carrying moments of my life with me. and I'm carrying memories with me that maybe don't have a physical representation, but I'm, like, in my mind, but I'm making that physical representation for myself. I think some ways to do this is like junk journaling, but try doing a junk box this year. Cinema tickets, receipts from a date, a note from somebody at concert wristband, a postcard, a menu, a chocolate wrapper. Like, it doesn't have to be neat.
当我还是个孩子的时候，显然你现在不应该那样做了，所以我很抱歉，但我那时是个孩子。没人知道任何事。我过去常收集豆豆娃。我过去常，我不知道，收集小雕像，我仍然有很多。这在物理上非常让人踏实，并且在物理上感觉我正带着我生命中的时刻。我正带着记忆，也许它们没有物理表现，但我，就像，在我的脑海里，但我正在为自己制作那个物理表现。我认为做这件事的一些方法是像“垃圾手账”，但今年尝试做一个“垃圾盒”。电影票、约会的收据、音乐会腕带上的便条、明信片、菜单、巧克力包装纸。它不需要整洁。
You know, nobody's going to put this in a museum. Maybe they will. I don't think they will. It's a time capsule for yourself. Or do like one scrapbook page per month, just one, one photo, one sentence, that's it. Something like March was hard. I did X, Y, Z. It was a photo that I took on my iPhone. But, you know, I spent some really nice time in nature. And now I have that, and I remember that, and I can come back to that. On this note, my final tip, half of romanticizing your 20s is providing ways again for you to really experience hindsight and for you to really reflect on the past and how far you've come and how meaningful past experiences were to the story
你知道，没人会把它放进博物馆。也许他们会。我不认为他们会。这是给自己的时间胶囊。或者像每个月做一页剪贴簿，就一页，一张照片，一句话，就这样。比如三月很艰难。我做了X、Y、Z。这是我在iPhone上拍的一张照片。但是，你知道，我在大自然中度过了一些非常美好的时光。现在我有了那个，我记得那个，我可以回到那个。说到这里，我的最后一个建议，浪漫化二十岁的一半是再次为你提供真正体验回顾的方法，让你真正反思过去，反思你走了多远，反思过去的经历对你正在创造的故事有多么重要。
that you are creating. So with that in mind, I think the biggest thing you can do for your 20s and romanticizing them is to make vlogs for yourself and yourself only. Let me explain this. When I broke up with my first proper boyfriend when I was at university, I remember feeling like so deeply sad and so unhappy. And so what I started doing was vlogging myself crying. And I know that sounds ridiculous, but I would talk to myself on the camera and be like, I just am having such a hard time. I miss this about him.
所以考虑到这一点，我认为你能为你的二十岁做的最重要的事情，就是为你自己，也仅仅为你自己制作视频博客。让我解释一下。当我在大学时与我的第一个正式男友分手时，我记得感觉非常悲伤和不快乐。所以我开始做的事情是拍摄自己哭泣的视频博客。我知道这听起来很荒谬，但我会对着镜头对自己说，我只是过得很艰难。我怀念他的这一点。
I miss that about him. And I would keep doing that until I felt like I didn't need to do it anymore. And only recently did I find those videos again. I found like 20 of them. And I was like, wow, I feel so happy that I documented that. I feel so happy I now have the privilege of getting to sit back with hindsight and be like, we really did get better. And everything really turned out the way it was meant to be. And we didn't want to end up with him anyways. That is such a privilege. I genuinely feel so lucky that I had that opportunity. And again, it's this hindsight. It's this part of you that only gets to find experiences like romantic in the future.
我怀念他的那一点。我会一直这样做，直到我觉得我不再需要这样做为止。直到最近我才再次找到那些视频。我找到了大概20个。我当时想，哇，我感到非常高兴我记录了那个。我感到非常高兴我现在有特权可以坐下来回顾，并说，我们确实变得更好了。一切确实都按照它应该有的方式发展了。无论如何，我们都不想和他在一起。那真是一种特权。我真心觉得我很幸运我有那个机会。而且，这是回顾。这是你的一部分，只有在未来才能发现像浪漫这样的经历。
And if you don't give yourself the opportunity to fully resubmerge in those moments, obviously you can do it in other ways. But like sometimes you miss that. You miss how heartbreak, rejection, pain, terrible things, losing your job, going broke. Like, forget that it's all going to be okay and that it's all taking you somewhere else. And so starting that practice now of genuinely filming yourself when you feel the need to talk, when you feel like this is a moment or a memory that you are going to want to return to is a fantastic way to romanticize what you're going through.
如果你不给自己机会完全沉浸在那些时刻中，显然你可以用其他方式做到。但有时你会错过那个。你会错过心碎、拒绝、痛苦、糟糕的事情、失业、破产的感觉。就像，忘记这一切都会好起来，忘记这一切都在把你带向别处。所以从现在开始养成那个习惯，当你觉得需要说话时，当你觉得这是一个你以后会想回到的时刻或记忆时，真诚地拍摄自己，这是浪漫化你正在经历的事情的一种绝佳方式。
It's a fantastic way to just, yeah, I feel like I've said it enough times. It's a fantastic way to create the story and to have parts of the story that you can reflect back on and then project forward with to see that things are going to get better. in the future. Now, to drill one final point home before we conclude this episode, contrary to all the nice sentimental tips I've given so far to like vlog yourself crying, keep junk in a box, whatever, sometimes the most romantic, loving thing you can do for yourself is just let yourself fall apart, to just let yourself feel like crap about a situation. Our 20s are a hard decade. This is hard. You're a hard. You're a very hard. You're a very hard.
这是一种绝佳的方式，只是，是的，我觉得我已经说了很多次了。这是一种绝佳的方式来创造故事，并拥有故事中你可以回顾的部分，然后向前展望，看到事情在未来会变得更好。现在，在结束本集之前，为了强调最后一个观点，与我目前给出的所有关于拍摄自己哭泣、把垃圾放在盒子里等感性的建议相反，有时你能为自己做的最浪漫、最充满爱的事情，就是让自己崩溃，让自己对某种情况感觉糟糕。二十岁是一个艰难的十年。这很难。你是一个……你是一个非常……你是一个非常……
a baby adult. You are in your infancy of adulthood. And as you mature, there is so much to learn. And part of that learning is through pain, which really sucks. But I think we all learn that the older we get. Practice emotional acceptance. Basically, allow negative emotions to pass through you rather than fighting them, lean back into them. This has been found to actually predict better psychological outcomes. If you're depressive symptoms, less anxiety over time compared to constantly trying to put a positive spin on on absolutely everything. I know that sounds contradictory, but you are allowed to be messy and you're allowed to be
一个成年婴儿。你处于成年的初期。随着你的成熟，有很多东西要学。而学习的一部分是通过痛苦，这真的很糟糕。但我认为我们随着年龄的增长都会学到这一点。练习情绪接纳。基本上，允许负面情绪流过你，而不是与它们抗争，向后靠在它们身上。这已被发现实际上能预测更好的心理结果。如果你有抑郁症状，随着时间的推移，焦虑会减少，而不是不断地试图在绝对所有事情上加上积极的色彩。我知道这听起来很矛盾，但你被允许变得混乱，你被允许
sad and you're allowed to feel lost and not necessarily know that you're going to feel better, but just hope. Like you're allowed to feel sorry for yourself sometimes. I feel like we need to say that. It's actually a good thing. You don't need to fix it. You don't need to rush through it. just name the emotion accurately, care for your body in the most basic sense, movement, food,
悲伤，你被允许感到迷茫，不一定知道你会感觉更好，但只是希望。就像你有时被允许为自己感到难过。我觉得我们需要说出来。这实际上是一件好事。你不需要修复它。你不需要匆忙度过它。只需准确地命名这种情绪，以最基本的方式照顾你的身体，运动、食物、
sleep, water. And when you're ready, you can maybe look for the silver lining. You can maybe add the narrative back in if you want to do that. Sometimes, honestly, the hard feelings are where you feel most alive. Because it, like, it hurts so much, it almost feels good. Do you know what I mean? Do you know what I mean by that? Like, the, like, the pain. almost feels satisfying and gratifying because it reminds you that you're alive and it reminds you that you are here. And as bad as that is and as much you're like, this is just ripping me to shreds, there's always a parallel happy experience that's going to balance things out. Well, I at least believe that. I really do believe in the balance of the universe.
睡眠、水。当你准备好时，你也许可以寻找一线希望。如果你想这样做，你也许可以把叙事加回去。有时，老实说，艰难的感觉是你感觉最活着的地方。因为它，就像，它太痛了，几乎感觉很好。你知道我的意思吗？你知道我那是什么意思吗？就像，那种痛苦。几乎感觉令人满意和满足，因为它提醒你你还活着，它提醒你你在这里。尽管它很糟糕，尽管你觉得这简直要把我撕成碎片，但总有一个平行的快乐体验会平衡一切。好吧，至少我相信这一点。我真的相信宇宙的平衡。
When you experience bad, good will return. So to summarize, romanticizing your talk 20s isn't a trick to make bad things always feel good and magical all the time. That is impossible. You cannot act against the physics of life. It's not a way to stop bad things from happening. It's just a way of stopping bad things from becoming the only narrative you tell yourself about your life. We know this works because psychologically, we have evidence for methods like cognitive re-appraisal. We have evidence for attention bias theory. We have evidence that our beliefs about a situation do allow us to better control the outcome. And it matters to us. I think this whole process matters to us because in a time is turbulent and ever-changing as our 20s, having that stable,
当你经历坏事时，好事会回来。所以总结一下，浪漫化你的二十岁并不是一个让坏事总是感觉良好和神奇的技巧。那是不可能的。你不能违背生活的物理规律。这不是阻止坏事发生的方法。这只是阻止坏事成为你对自己生活讲述的唯一叙事的方法。我们知道这有效，因为在心理学上，我们有认知重评等方法的证据。我们有注意偏向理论的证据。我们有证据表明我们对某种情况的信念确实让我们能更好地控制结果。这很重要。我认为整个过程对我们很重要，因为在像二十岁这样动荡和不断变化的时代，拥有那种稳定的、
coherent story of like, this is all linked. There is an invisible string that runs through this all, stops us from discarding or just wanting to push through hard things and lets us just feel them and just be like, cool. I'm here. I'm in the belly of life. If there's, If it's not going to go well, at least I'm going to feel it as deeply as I can. So I hope you enjoyed this episode. If you have made it this far and you were listening on Spotify, leave a little comment down below. How are you planning to romanticize your 20s? Is there something that you do that I didn't mention that you think is important?
连贯的故事，就像，这一切都是相互关联的。有一根无形的线贯穿这一切，阻止我们丢弃或只是想强行度过困难的事情，让我们只是感受它们，就像，酷。我在这里。我在生活的腹中。如果它不会顺利，至少我会尽可能深刻地感受它。所以我希望你喜欢这一集。如果你已经听到了这里，并且你是在Spotify上收听的，请在下面留下一点评论。你打算如何浪漫化你的二十岁？有什么我没提到但你认为很重要的事情吗？
As always, huge thank you to our researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions and her help on this episode. She is truly amazing. Know the drill by now, but until next time. Be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We're going to talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
一如既往，非常感谢我们的研究员利比·科尔伯特对本集的贡献和帮助。她真的很棒。现在你应该知道流程了，但直到下次。注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再谈。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我在我的播客《2%》中。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J.
我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方搜索“TWO%”。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何幸存下来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我的意思是，那是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有比这更重要的黑人年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师和主持人，基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在任何地方都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same. same thing. Greg, a lesbian,
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让双胞胎怀孕。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，欧文斯女士，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋，
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app,
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序收听《Love Trapped》播客，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Apple Podcasts，或任何你获取播客的地方。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们采取了行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。